the Joe Rogan experience now what other
stuff do you do in terms of
self-improvement should I ask for
Hanukkah no I'm I'm can't buy I think a
little like you as I've researched you
that I'm constantly reading things like
all of the time always nonfiction
however no friction at all no I I just
know that's interesting for someone who
produces a lot of fiction well I what I
like is I yes that's right what I have
found in my life the the like the for me
the foundational creative ingredients
are in ingredient to a creative equation
like making a movie or a TV show or
painting or is counterpoint so I have
found that I'm dreamy enough myself you
know like I you know and I've read of
course all joseph campbell stuff so i
kind of understand formats of myths and
the hair with a thousand faces and and
and i particularly liked underdog
stories there are so many types of
underdog stories that it's um so anyway
so i have that basic knowledge and then
when i learn a subject let's say i learn
the subject of architecture or physics
or a little bit of chemistry or whatever
the you know it's it's all like from an
archaeological perspective because it's
all new to me so i found for example
when i produce the movie 8 mile which is
about hip hop right is about it battles
in detroit first i thought mmm
i could even go back further i'll could
do this quickly though i thought i me
should get like the hottest you know
video director the coolest guy and i
wont say those names but there there
were the guys that were very visible at
being the best at those video those hot
videos and then it occurred to me i
should get somebody that approaches it
again archaeologically where everything
is a discovery so i hired someone they
knew nothing about hip hop what was
passionate about wanting to do the movie
and he was named Curtis hands
he's deceased right now but he won I
think believe two oscars for LA
Confidential hmm it was kind of a
classic American filmmaker that looked
at everything was sort of a discovery
lens and that's why you were able to see
if if I pick the video guy that thinks
he knows everything about hip-hop then
all the little nuances that are new to
the audience's eyes would have never
been shot because he'd think oh
everybody knows that stuff that's it get
the good stuff you know yeah and so
sometimes Authority on top of authority
doesn't work out well and I found that
Mike my for my career all I did was
write and produce comedies for the first
17 years of my movie career starting
with night shift and then splash and
Parenthood and Nutty Professor and liar
liar and I could you know a lot of
comedies a lot of five Eddie Murphy
thing you know Jim Carrey three times
you know and what I found was Jewish
writers Christian actors and the Jewish
words they go Jew writers go I'm actor
and [ __ ] is like when Jewish people say
it's the Christian mia the Catholic guy
it's always I made eight movies I think
with Tom Hanks but he's he's like the
Gary Cooper or he's the Christian guy
with the Jewish writers always why it
works why do you want you know good
Christian and Christian not funny really
yeah it just doesn't play what's wrong
with you on Jew denomination only one
Jew on Jew kind of worked in the last
Woody Allen and they weren't in meteoric
hits he was just like you know he he was
sort of dominated the ethos you know of
you know I mean he of comedy in the 70s
and 80s but yeah but it just doesn't
work you can't really see but you can I
could name I'm a Judd Apatow talented
Jewish writer director usually he's got
the
guys that are like not they're just not
that they're Catholic Christian guys you
know like our girls right I mean who's
the chair the chicken trainwreck the
Melissa McCarthy McCarthy she's Catholic
right
he's a Jew is like that's the
counterpoint is what works isn't
trainwreck Amy Schumer is it Melissa
McCarthy oh you might be right oh it
might be both yeah
it's both oh thank god thank every good
tiebreaker
[Applause]